well it may be summer but that doesn't
change the speed limit in school zones
where some classes are now in their
summer session eight news now reporter
Brian will tagged along with police
officers as they caught drivers speeding
right through school zones
Clark County School District police are
cracking down on speeders in school
zones writing nearly 15 citations just
during our time with them in one of
these school zones it's about the kids
safety it's not it's not about anything
else I've seen many many people fly
through the school zones I've been
honked in at a school zone because they
thought it was going too slow it's it's
a safety for the children you know it's
our responsibility as adults and drivers
to follow the speed zone signs in the
last nine months nearly a hundred
children were hit within school zones
here in Clark County
beating increases during summer so
police want drivers to know those
flashing school zone signs are there for
a reason during our time with the
officers they clocked the highest
speeding drivers we had three vehicles
go by 42 38 and 36 and three of us
pulled over all three of those Vehicles
along with speeding there are other
things most drivers are not aware of
that you can't do within a school zone
that includes u-turns or driving past
another vehicle I know everybody has a
place to go things to do people are
running late we totally understand but
sometimes those mistakes can turn into
lifelong problems if the lights are on
whether this their summer school regular
school you follow the the law you know
they're there for a purpose they're not
there because somebody forgot to turn
the switch off they're there to protect
the children school is still in summer
session until the end of July and if
you're driving through one of these
school zones just a reminder if the road
is touching School property it's about a
15 mile per hour Zone if the road is a
little bit further away from the school
it's around 25 miles per hour reporting
at Cashman Middle School Brian will
eight news now